i'm so excited you guys goodbye i'm
really [ __ ] excited i'm excited for
you but also in case you didn't already
know um and i feel like i try to say
this frequently oh no timed out got it
um just so people are aware uh i'm not
good at taylor
just play a lot of it
ricky benjamin is halo 2 right yes oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah that song kupa sings on
the soundtrack but not in the game blow
me away had like permanent residence on
every mp3 player
the first video i ever made was a
screenshot montage in halo 3 to blow hey
group
[Music]
[Music]
or whatever it is
[Laughter]
you've got to move
blow me away i don't remember the lyrics
all day if i heard it i'd be alright
oh
look at swag we're in good hands yeah
there's an incubus song but only if you
went to a certain secret area when
you're on the yeah you've got to keep it
it's the incubus secret
it's a really off-putting weird song all
right yeah i got that on the like
gamestop promotional mini soundtrack
disc
yeah i'm gonna hang out with my friends
i'm gonna go with you guys i'm yeah i'm
just following lawrence i got a br
oh did you hear this banker son of a
[ __ ]
where's the team where's the enemy team
they're killing our single teammate
whoa
whoa that's nice
oh yeah i see the sniper killing swag
licking him right now
camo is much oh i finished him off there
nice once you pop that shield real good
you got a [ __ ] rocket launcher dude
they're trying to snipe me oh oh oh
no no no no no that was unfair the game
goes right as i got shot in the face oh
lawrence it's just ending everybody a
shame
getting mileage out of that spanker
thank you
for taking that one oh
damn oh how do we feel about about the
assault rifle we feel like i should use
it
i like it it seems fine
yeah at the right range of course
but you really gotta like empty the
whole thing into somebody
you can at least kill somebody with one
clip i usually may as well [ __ ] throw
it away
yeah
usually i'm like i'm gonna get this out
of my hands yeah for me it's like
spray it at them but also close the
distance so i can melee
that makes sense
yeah
that was almost dead [ __ ] i don't have
people i'm fully dead
oh me the strongest will survive
lead me to heaven when we die
oh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
my both of my friends are dead what
happened i'm back i'm right behind you
alana spartans never die
in action missing in action
let's get out of here that ghost is bad
dude sniper oh [ __ ] oh my gosh
finally dunstan
did you shoot that ghost with that's
insane
whatever that thing is
hydra
yeah [ __ ] them up
i love a good old melee trade
i know it's so funny whenever that
happens like i laugh every time i'm not
even mad i'm like
we punched each other in the face
because we realized they're so
yeah
i'm grabbing the sniper right now let's
see if i can do any work with it
oh yeah i don't see anyone right dude oh
you got the rocket launcher okay we're
controlling the power weapons right now
i got a shotgun
i'm shutting snipies right now
dusty grandma died
no no
oh look a saber it's a it's a saber
energy sword no it's a
oh somebody throwing your grenades in us
nice shot lawrence oh there's a bunch of
them behind us who the [ __ ] did that
lo a lot of behind us i'm scared i'm
afraid
ammunition
[ __ ] you your ammunition is it dude
oh i killed dusty grandma no no
so sorry
she just needs some moisture
who's out there laurence powder right
now that hurts about a rifle
oh so many grenades
got one of them this oh nice shot
oh
baby
[Music]
oh that's three jesus jesus christ whoa
look at us go halfway to victory
that was a good shot damn
he dun did me i've only got uh two shots
left on the sniper so i'll try and get
some mileage out of it
boom
there's another one
i'm giving it away oh nice shot i'm out
of ammo i'm at ammo
i do still have the shoddy though
um wow how strange
you're way over there
hey
chat um uh mugs there's somebody that
you need to ban it's weird that he's
left as many messages as he has gross
get it out of here
i'm not able to ban i don't know what i
want to ban him you guys oh that's a
great maybe i have to see what he said
oh i did through the time oh no oh i got
[ __ ] up they shot it while i was
holding it that makes sense just up a
bit
you'll find it
oh yeah
please clip up
oh that's a stalker rifle thanks jeff
the jared unbanned him
i want his band and then unbanned him
you just unbanned him
oh no
power items incoming power items
incoming
i'm never gonna recover from all the
snipes i've made all this
shot i don't recognize this map it isn't
uh no it's not sword base but the ship
from sword base is here right
oh god that's a sniper oh god
nice lawrence are you playing with a
mouse and keyboard
i'm doing a messing keyboard i am too
right now
feels good yeah it does feel pretty good
okay i'm gonna
oh hold on i'm gonna try and get to you
or unless it's dangerous uh no i got
sniped and died immediately so okay so
there's a sniper the active what
i would say
for this game
with the controller though i'm currently
playing with my keyboard because i don't
know
nice teammate oh all his friends are
here thank you for the sub snake i'm
picking them
because i'm using oh spanker forgetting
about pings x is pig that's right that's
right
there's they're running together it's
remaining one of them's got the rocket
launcher five minutes remaining five
minutes
i'm sorry i sort of stole that kill
that's all right no
please take it there were too many of
them we did a bat
i can't hold all these kills
there's too many of them
you turned off your auto aim enemies on
me
oh nice laurence thank you for cleaning
that one up i would like to get scared
it told me there were power weapons
coming and i haven't seen any and i am
sad
spanker is 23 seconds away
uh active camo's got 20 seconds
no you [ __ ] joking [ __ ] oh damn it
that was a very messy kill i got really
out of control there
seven hours either that's gonna be on
the weekend what what if we just played
halo all weekend can i pitch that to you
guys
that's what i want to do what if we land
get some energy drinks what if we land
there's a hole where i would just like
have halo reach lan parties and it was
amazing yeah dude
you guys actually want to do a lan party
i'm down with that why not that'd be
[ __ ] dumb
it'd be super good
i can't wait for forge to be a thing
because i loved making halo maps
i never really [ __ ] with forge i
enjoyed what other people did but i
never i don't know i've never really
built stuff outside of minecraft and i
haven't touched minecraft since the
[ __ ] tree incident
oh it brings me it makes me sad i i tell
people about it frequently i think i
need to talk to my therapist about it
like i'm frequently like and i built
this tree and i put hours of work into
that tree i got the rocket launcher and
i'm invisible
what happened
damn it how dare you i'm sorry i'm sorry
get out of here stupid [ __ ]
oh no
only the strongest will survive
lead me to heaven when we die
well
i'm not getting off the mongoose is less
cool now
oh how
click left stick i think
i'm so happy
oh you [ __ ] this [ __ ] up oh
god incredible
the perfect video the perfect video game
oh i love halo what a great time
that was the perfect ending
[Laughter]
[Music]
i got an achievement
[Laughter]
cool
oh i love it this is that was my first
game of halo infinite you guys
and it was incredible
i had a great time
oh asset errors you'd like to know more
about the tree okay so i spent hours
building this tree in this minecraft
server that we had hours and it was
[ __ ] beautiful
it was massive because i had i i
basically like
built the base the trunk of a tree with
wood but then i was growing other trees
on top of it i would like plant wood um
dirt grow tree and i would clear the
area above it so that it would then grow
up so it was organically grown so the
tree had trees on it and then i would go
through and i would manually remove the
dirt so it was like this [ __ ] massive
trunk with all of these like branches
off of it and you like nailed this
kind of
natural asymmetry that a tree has yeah
because it was kind of natural um yeah
and
i had built pathways through like the
the the tree leaves so it was like
iwakian kind of like it [ __ ] it
[ __ ] ruled um and then somehow
grifters found our server which i would
have thought was private i don't even
know how they found it
and they burned it down
oh yeah they just dumped lava everywhere
and of course the wood's flammable and
the tree went up the whole thing we're
down they filled my hobbit hole with
lava too
hot it's heartbreaking oh what a server
though oh
i kind of did create singing
star wars all night yeah yeah star wars
exclusively all night did you guys see
the teaser trailer with pablo no i
haven't even caught up on it yet
did it come out today yeah it's it's
pretty short but i haven't seen it you
could probably check it out in the lobby
um
but uh i'm just launching
because i got it on pc
should we dive out of this game
no no wait you can carry on okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're already over
there yeah we could see them they could
see this oh my gosh
i'm just picking him with a br right now
uh one above you
he's got an overshield i didn't think
that would work
but i tried
that dude steamrolled me oh let me add
to the i'm gonna i'm gonna avoid that
right now i think i'm guessing i have to
do a little bit of create a profile
stuff oh [ __ ]
no you you don't have to do anything
okay well i need to put settings on
already
you need to put the settings on
yeah i gotta put settings on and thing
yeah that's fine
allow it oh nice jacob he told you not
to put settings on
allow it
the uh
the students become the master i know
we're gonna go
[ __ ]
oh my god i'm so [ __ ] frantic when i
try to hit someone it's terrible
but i did it
uh
[Music]
yeah every five minutes i think about
malignant florence we watched uh
malignant last night me and uh
rahul and jacob and tara and john
uh have you seen it
not yet
everyone said about it is 100 my kind of
deal so my highlight of the evening
though was that um jacob killed margaret
as we call her
um
i think it's what he's actually called
it like yeah we and he did it two
minutes after the network test was
supposed to end
it was pretty sick yeah i mean
yeah the network test
we should probably leave huh i hard
crashed oh
oh oh oh oh okay i made it finish it
no it gave it to him oh i had him but i
didn't think about it what do i do
we just became friends recently
we didn't invite you okay cool oh it
looks beautiful in my ultra wide my
super ultra wide survive
oh man
you're going to get to see
a lot more of the game
you have yeah
ultrawide for me it is it is beautiful
i'm going to make sure that who was
think was the what was it what's the
stink song
okay okay okay i like the settings don't
like the the uh you're happy with the
settings oh yeah default settings all
right yeah all right i'm fire team
leader what
i'm fighting leader i think we're all
separate from each other yeah we're not
even oh that's why because we're in
different parties i'm joining on jacob
again
okay i trust you do i need to do
anything i need i'm looking for you
right now i can see you i'm
offline so yeah click click uh just join
on me i think oh it says he was invited
malignant weird
is it
no we're on pc
yeah let me just cosplay anyways
oh if you can see me there right yeah i
got an invite from you but you can't
invite me
i'm never gonna you can invite us
i know it's bad oh the no the hit the
hoobastank one from from
halo 2 is the
we are connected well milan is not here
i can't see him
i should be am i not we are together
it looks like i'm
i'm
i'm gonna invite everybody to rock game
okay where do invites go how are you
guys finding or seeing mine was a
windows notification oh lawrence and i
are together okay um
maybe it's a windows notes so i should
just join rahul's game
yeah
join is it
part of oh [ __ ]
yeah
oh
how do we invite lawrence
lawrence should be able to join on one
of us i can probably join on jacob
join me we fall in line one at a time
well perfect perfect yeah i just had
laurence as a friend anyway
don't get intimidated by my gamer score
there
i'm going to go listen to the halo 2 it
doesn't show you gamer school uh what
what is the point of this game
all right
so should i just go multiplayer
really yeah quick players play
we got a full team
i will stay unless i something
i could yeah like every other word in
that song i didn't quite get no i have
no idea what it's about no idea the
incubus one was just like
i am losing sight again i don't know
what the song's about
[Music]
the next the next two two lines of fire
your guns it's time to run
oh yeah
[Music]
the world needs to top stop taking
breaking benjamin for granted that there
have bomb
this song that is uh a reference to the
wizard of oz
that i really like
um
[Music]
oh to it again and actually understand
it's good i like it a lot
i mean it's pretty [ __ ] literal it's
like
he's from the perspective of a witch so
like the lyrics are because i'm going to
get you on your little dog tomb there's
a yellow brick road that we follow back
home
i guess so
that's a frame rate name all of that
oh it's all chunky for you it's curdled
oh no you got cottage cheese just like
those
those things that we had the other night
they were supposed to say the name of
cruz oh this is ugly oh god it's
juggling
this looks this looks like cyberpunk
oh yeah this is the reach map it's cool
it's so awesome [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
there's like a part that has a there's
like a nightclub that plays a song i
think oh that's my favorite kind of
nightclub
yeah this map this map
the finish line oh it's captured
[ __ ] yeah oh
my body my body is spinning forever
cap and sea land some captaincy only the
strongest will survive
the rest of the song doesn't doesn't
count
oh i'm surrounded
oh
okay
how to throw a grenade i don't remember
uh i think it's g by default i changed
it to f because that's that's yeah yeah
it should be f he's an outrageous she is
too far away oh that's way too far so
it's f is melee for me right now
no it's g for me i think it's both
actually oh my god i'm doing really bad
c is a lot nicer do you want to come to
see with me mate
i will do
i don't think it works as an innuendo
when we would just think of the ocean oh
okay cool i love that i love that scene
he's scared
he's british she's loud
to bravo
i hope you get banned off twitch
because you said that we all get banned
oh [ __ ] off alana i'm playing really
badly on this one oh no no no no no no
he has a friend
yeah classy kill
oh they're at c
slayer
nothing happened
[Music]
but it's still spicy over there yeah no
i think i got rid of this most of the
spices oh no the spice came back the
spice came back
nice thank you thank you um i do want to
acknowledge that there is a lyric that
is literally i will stay unless i may
yeah whatever the [ __ ] that means
explain it benjamin
benjamin broke me
damn it
somebody's afk
so get your free assassinations i guess
yes okay i'm heading to b will those
give me a point
i think if they're challenges yet
[ __ ]
look at us halo boys
yeah look at us halo i will legitimately
see if we can figure out a way to land
this weekend because that would be sick
all we have to do is yank our computers
together
yeah
you have a switch
you mean halo and this is over there
hello
having a great time so far cody
oh no no no sorry not the console no i
knew you got him
um do you want to push a lads let's push
it i'm already there oh yeah in the a
push it real good
charlie push him right in the air
oh what the [ __ ] they're beating us oh
yeah they were at the very beginning
oh
there's some would be there's someone b
right now jack b
yeah
all right yeah i didn't realize that we
weren't winning so that's on us
yeah
i'm playing really badly you guys it's a
lot of this is
making really good this is my first game
so i i can have freebie
but my frame rate is like 20 frames per
second it's running really well for me
um it could be a monitor thing
yeah maybe that really
it's butchery smooth don't you dare make
it anything less than maximum resolution
uh i'm bi
i just respawned by c so i can head that
way okay
and they're also just not here
okay
well then i'll go to oh they're just
going to be there
yeah they're going to be behind oh yeah
they kill me yeah oh my gosh i died
right in the back
assisted by alt milky i don't like that
i don't like it at all oh [ __ ]
nice
good kill
oh they're capping c
yeah but we're capping a sorry
[ __ ] i really have to change the
settings between yeah
yeah you gotta activate gamer mode
i'm coming
oh yeah you should get him get him yeah
nice
don't you dare shoot me right now
rahul what
no it looked like you were doing
something because it wasn't red
oh they're coming for us it'd be
nice
i think i marked enemies maybe
oh yeah
yeah
i keep hitting x instead of c
enemy team scoring
try to cap c guys come help i'm good
i'm coming oh grenade
yeah we did it team scored
somebody get the cinder what they did
oh the pain
thank you thank you thank you uh yeah
super dead
yeah jacob did die
my body got disintegrated
disintegrated [ __ ] i'm pushing a oh
they're going to be
i'm pretty far away from everything
the [ __ ] out of my shop damn it too many
of them
call me friends i avenge you
going to run it behind her hole with the
grenade launcher again
i'm at a
they're going to be coming from b i
thinks and they're at c b i'm pushing c
what do you guys want to do let's roll
together let's roll together yeah keep
it keep it b b let's go to b okay yep
there's one of them here i think we'll
just be kind of chasing after them just
fine
oh no
one what was that giant explosion i
pressed their keep pressing [ __ ]
buttons
oh all right we got b let's let's push
the c let's push the c let's push the c
it's still oh my god family who the [ __ ]
i'm right behind you alana
watch this come on come on come on
nice work
look it's dude
right through the middle i'm scared yeah
yeah we can go through the middle
i'm right behind you i am one shot
though
throwing grenades up into a right i
really need to fix the settings man this
is this is happening
oh one behind me
we did it all right we gotta push let's
go
but nobody's doing anything
at a time
we literally are running in circles
but what else are we supposed to do
let's [ __ ] this guy
what's going on
like i [ __ ] up
i will stay on the enemy
enemy team scoring
he's literally running around
oh got a commando here
[Music]
i love that for us
but the points
yeah yeah
nice and they're on b
and right behind you alana going towards
speed
i thought i'd just try to change up the
strat and i failed then it didn't work
oh thank you i didn't realize what gun i
picked up it was a sentinel beam
it's pretty dramatic isn't it
somehow this absolute loop of us just
running in circles chasing them is
actually kind of evening us out a little
bit a little bit we're catching up
i just pressed
everybody
and nothing happened like
except we're catching up my dude is like
face down in the dirt and then just a
defeat
yeah we're almost there it was happening
we could stop for a second raul to
figure out those settings
yeah it's super um
yeah it's awful
rampage might you might say
i'm gonna go get myself some water i
will be right back it's gonna be the
ultra wide right i need i need a refill
i'll be right back cool
why why are we playing a custom game all
right
you do all this i mean i'm not opposed
we're playing each other ruffle what all
right
what are you doing
what are you doing
that's what i said what are you doing
what are you doing literally
literally what are you doing what are
you doing
what are you doing
this bit is so confusing i know
like but actually what are you doing
what are you doing
why is this happening
what do you think you can do
oh it's loading
why is it loading
why are we doing this
it's not it's multiplayer quick play no
it's
not
no it's no it's it's absolutely not you
chose a custom game
hey it's like oh my god okay
that's wrong
it's okay
that is not what you did
what have you done
[Laughter]
all right
what is happening i think it actually is
quick play and we're playing oddball now
on the other what what i think i think
you guys telling the truth i think he's
i think we're the dumb dumb wait what
yeah we're the big dogs we're the dumb
dumbest we are so dumb oh you're so dumb
you've got to hear this dude say the
word
thank you
but now rahul's gonna perform get that
ball somebody grab the ball
i might die jacob i'm trying but it's
getting out of hand out here oh [ __ ]
okay no no oh let me take that please
thank you
down right here [ __ ] you
come on where is
the skull i'm over here in a corner and
i'm scared i got you little boy
don't worry about it okay i'm gonna hang
out in the staircase can they see
probably
yeah probably right
why was that first game so
this controls that control's bad warm up
i did not like it wait for me don't
leave me
no no no no no no no
i'm hanging out in the back oh help
danger danger
where is
[Music]
is this your idea of a diplomatic
solution
it's like aggressive negotiations
got the ball you're going the enemy has
to pause
oh he had a spanker too and his friends
are here's mine
it's so good the ball
oh somebody hell is this a booster pick
up
get the ball the ball there we go
i'm dead
oh [ __ ] yo
that's the ball the ball
points at the ball hold it in the ball
oh
the coming after the ball
i did
oh my god it's incredible [ __ ] it's
very deranged protect the ball
i got the ball
in the ball
i killed them and took it all right
what do i do
just carry it
[Music]
oh
[Music]
somebody in my chat said damn it
probably get the ball which is great
bobby
bobby
there's too many of them oh i find this
very funny
[ __ ]
enemy has the ball
get the ball get the ball ball incoming
is the best one the one at the very
beginning it's the most successful
brilliant
this guy was very confused yeah he
didn't have a great time i sort of feel
bad
it's
okay we're at the point whoa the sound
of the central beam is amazing it is a
huge upgrade from what it is i'm trying
to play the objective but mike
flanagan's texting me loads of messages
oh no
tell him you're protecting the bottle
yeah no me too though same get in hell
no he's giving me uh mike right now i
was i was talking to him about malignant
so he's giving me the notifications for
like horrors i should actually watch oh
my god
what's happened here
i have no idea oh somebody's doing a
spin oh
i saw your attempt at flanking it was
very chill show your mouth was this
break was this joker going
yeah beat him up
give me the goddamn ball you sack of
[ __ ] insult him
i'm scared he's coming for me
oh that was mean
damn
okay um it's getting spicy out here guys
it got spicy it got spicy real fast
there's too many of them oh no
i think we spent most of that time
laughing so
and that's what matters it'll happen
oh there's another real halo with the
ball we found a long one
oh we missed it it's in the back
you've got this in the bag
enemy has the ball no
instead of grenading all the time it's
not great yeah let's go get that ball
let's go get the ball
bobby
too far away
why did you guys leave lawrence
i was yeah they were pushing well it's
pushing forward why do they take so much
[ __ ] bullets
oh no oh there he goes
spartans no we haven't i got it oh
they're right here
i just ran into them
when you land the mall
don't let them take the ball
oh is cam here hello kim what up welcome
back your grenades guys guys
we got a sharpen up pony boys
yep
one shot kills
we just we got a tidy we gotta tie it
right there
all right [ __ ]
i got it
i'm running towards rahul because he's
the closest to green nice all right
[ __ ] help glad help all right all
right i'm too busy being here
oh no it's just raw hole okay jacob's
here jacob's here
right in the butt here we go
the it has been revealed that i'm
holding the objective there's a sick
beach
all right it is actually we're next to
another cancun it's pretty sick
yeah i still have the ball dude
i'm here i don't know oh no oh no oh no
oh no around the corner
oh there's too many of them you lift
he's nope still that's still left still
that i'm leaving
now that there's too many [ __ ]
enemies
i got them both i got them both
what what behind us
it's a girl i absolutely got yelling
help from first that is absolutely your
first thing we invited him to play
tonight but he don't have a big night
nice raffle
why don't we hustle
enemy hurts
[ __ ] one shot kills
i think i killed him i think i killed
him oh if i didn't i was close
he's weird he's there he's weak
he's one shot
oh that's a good question can you can
you melee with the bowl like in previous
halos yeah you can't it isn't one shot
oh it's not a one-hand kill oh i'm
reloading the spanker right now heads up
nice kill
yeah around the corner
nearing victory baby who has the ball
which one where are you rolling's got it
you don't run away from us
sorry we kind of left him i guess yeah
we have the ball
yeah you're right we literally need to
pick it up for one [ __ ] second
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh my
god we do
okay he's separated idiot idiot idiot
get the [ __ ]
is
i like the version of the chorus where
you sing one line and it gets more
deranged every line
it is breaking benjamin
oh my god it is what's it called blew me
away it's called blowing me away from
the halo 2 soundtrack
but it was it was removed in like the
release right
it's but you can switch back to old
graphics and it's just
music too
i love that there you go put the link in
chat everybody gotta listen but they
don't have it in the new music but
basically you've already heard it so
yeah you've heard the whole yeah you
pretty much got the gist yeah but yeah
it's a it's on the when you're on a high
chair
chief and you're trying to
it's before the flood take over high
charity [ __ ] [ __ ] up and then there's
a room we're breaking benjamin plays i
love it
with no lyrics but it's awesome i would
really like to see them live
yeah fun time you said they don't fly or
something because they're scared of
playing yeah like one of them doesn't
like planes or something yeah so they
never leave or they just drive
everything let me confirm that that's
true
okay yeah they when they went to the uk
they sailed because they didn't want to
fly
whoa that's awesome yes ben finally will
not get on a plane
what's the problem that doesn't want to
break you guys want to hear the record
the horror recommendations from mike
that he gave me i would love to feature
some mike flanagan horror
recommendations on this stream let's get
it okay
mike's
recommended to me session nine
uh
which is on
it's like a minimalist film uh uh the
black coats daughter
blacko's daughter is pretty scary oh
really yeah
i love the way jacob just said that i
got nervous yeah um and then lake mungo
i ain't heard of any of these yeah he's
it's a he said it's like a
documentary
type
it's he said it's one of the scariest
things ever
uh and then classics resort exorcist the
thing and the fly this is as a result of
you telling him you watched it
yeah
he was like you should have asked me
before you ran ahead trying to watch
horror
without consulting him
yeah because i was like i have a few
questions about this
oh my god
um shall we continue it's you raphael
rahu is the leader
[Music]
he's getting so frail
yeah no he's trying to billy island [ __ ]
well you just you just sing really
breathy for some reason
should we do
you want to do like mungo yes that one
sounds good another minimalist
lb's in my chat says lake monkeys monkey
mike's head it feels like you're
watching a true climb dock one of the
most scariest things i've ever seen oh
my god that's it holy [ __ ]
my chat is backing up those claims wow
okay like mungo i love it should we do
it
um whenever okay
[ __ ] just [ __ ] whatever i pitched um
i don't think you will be unavailable
this weekend but i pitched uh a halo
lane
we could figure out a way to get
everybody in a room and [ __ ] play
something yeah i can do that
i'm not available saturday after eight
yes i'm not available friday
it would probably have to be saturday
yeah my goal but we could do during the
day
yeah
if you're down i can do it oh my god i
would love that i also have a spare pc
it's so long
okay what is this capture what is this
capture points oh and i'm buttery again
i'm still buttery beautiful i'm going
for the energy sword
what was your plan
i don't know what he was doing [ __ ] you
upstairs this is too many levels
a banjo character though because the
mungo is very
very
90's era platformer named
my favor i don't know what my favorite
thing about malignant is but the
soundtrack is up there
oh so much pixies
i don't think you're allowed to do that
off to fight club like it just makes
everyone think of fight club
oh wow that was a good punch
that was a good punch jacob you have an
energy sword you [ __ ] your ass i do you
got that
i've not been picking up anything holy
weapons i haven't i haven't either
actually i'm just running between
the enemy has captured
the enemies
i've only got one capture and two kills
on the bottom of our team yeah
oh nice nice jacob you betcha you all
want to roll out to see
yeah do it
let's do this
are we going to do the same thing
it seems very weird that this is this is
like this is the gameplay oh i would
think
oh my god where'd that person come don't
worry about it he's [ __ ] dead yeah
don't even [ __ ] worry about that
shield stronghold bravo
oh
i got stuck what happened wow he [ __ ]
us up he stuck both of us you killed him
with the energy sword right i did hot i
think i really ran out of ammo too that
was a spicy time heading to be uh
slightly combat so far multiplayer is
fantastic i'm having a great time i'm
very happy great it feels good team
scoring
you got one behind you yeah i tried to
slide out from under him
loner yes
no i just like saying that
somebody in my chat said my favorite
part of malignant is when it ended
i enjoyed watching it but i thought it
was [ __ ] dumb i'm invisible
i have a problem with i have a problem
with
actually
like criticizing movies because it's my
okay you don't know who you're gonna end
up working
politely
how do i criticize it politely oh my god
the pixies were great
that's your criticism
your polite criticism is pixi's pretty
good
pretty good enemy team thank you sam
wella thanks for this oh i'm gonna get
smacked in the ass oh my butthole
oh no
jacob's buttocks
your team okay are you guys getting
headshots i feel like i'm never getting
headshots um yeah i'm getting headshots
right nice
that got messy pretty fast they all
grenaded us at once
wild
we do pretty frequently the drumple i
was saying i invited bruce to play with
us tonight
okay let's go 69 nice
nice what the f how did he get oh that
was great
died immediately oh yeah but this guy's
one guy you guys got taken out now
i'm pushing c
there's one running towards c
there you go another one on bravo damn
oh my god that guy killed me immediately
going for the sword i'm confessing it i
i couldn't even [ __ ] see oh he was
camo'ed
good news i just got an achievement
nice damn you still commenting
you're some kind of gamer boy i'll go to
a camera
don't worry about it ladies cut records
and i popped you back
i knew he was there he just like just
sat and let him [ __ ] punch me in the
face okay
and that's my finest track
yeah
nice jacob he didn't see you coming
who [ __ ] got me
where are you going i'm pushing them
[Music]
yeah
it's actually the only thing about our
culture
white isn't a culture
you know this that's what i'm saying
it's our entire staple it's just
it's just breaking benjamin
oh i just tried to take on the whole
[ __ ] team and i don't know nascar
oh yeah he sure does have a sword yeah
yeah he does he's right he has a sword
oh vr bro don't turn him out
well he can oh i love mayonnaise he can
stay at sea he can [ __ ] stay at sea
you know what half c chocolate he's
there chicken fries
what kind of tip do you think that is
oh [ __ ] watch out
[Laughter]
he's shooting hey he's shooting he's
shooting no you don't swordman
damn it he got me he got me too laura's
behind you and above
jacob's jacob's being a right virgin
right now he's got 17 kills
no one would know from this game
he's too strong
he must be oh nice laurence
no he got you too that dude is on a kill
streak oh no that wasn't that
someone else ran up and killed me
holy [ __ ]
what's happened what's happened what
happened to the boy hello at b happy
[Music]
yeah i couldn't see him it keeps
happening
there's a lot of them over there just
throw grenades in that hole yeah that's
what i did but i'm out grenade that's a
question samwell i don't know yeah my
twitch shot's lovely we have a great
time
there's a weird gun in this oh but hey
there's a couple at a laser that doesn't
make any sense can crack
um which is different
i don't play differently because i'm a
woman they're so quick with the [ __ ]
melee uh where is it [ __ ] uh it's
across the chasm
well
um
i killed a man
okay we're scoring yeah it's either you
didn't need to delete you didn't need to
delete that message all the time came
out jared you don't you need to do that
ow [ __ ]
the enemy okay
enemy teams
they really cleaned us up with that
sword
pushing to them
yes
oh look at that little sliver of health
damn
enemy team score
[Music]
that was dope dude
[Music]
we're all here
all right look at this [ __ ] guy lads
this is it buzz droids this is
not
anymore behind you behind me who which
one of us and where
one of you oh
oh my god so much just happened and i've
i just witnessed it i didn't partake it
was very stressful all right go and
proceed
oh my god that was so messy i got very
stressed
[ __ ] off
and i shall take it back oh yeah i
didn't have to i didn't have the shield
to handle that
my little wiener dude's name is fred
that's kind of a cool
you betcha i mean i played a [ __ ] load
of halo
all right i'm feeling good about that
one that was a good match i want to see
how many kills uh i was a mess but uh it
was a good time it's a good time
i didn't impress all the girls in my
kill count
jacob i'm always impressed by you
here we go hold on
you're the most impressive boy 28 kills
baby nice dude
[Music]
this guy's insane you should do anime
well let's go get disturbed again
[Laughter]
where's my water
it feels great in my opinion oh where's
your water like you already know it's
doing this yeah i can't find my water
[Laughter]
jacob just who are you what if what is
happening who are you that's raul who am
i it's raul coley
hey hey everybody look at my 28 kill
streak how do you like cheeseburgers oh
my god how do you feel about credit
cards
oh i think they have asperger's
yeah i don't love the way americans say
that
it's asperger's yeah americans americans
literally say asperger's
yeah yeah it's like a bit menu they see
the word and they go
aspergers this is spurges
what if i made it sound
sound like uncomfortable it's it sounds
like discomfort
asperger's
ah jeez
it's like i'm in
church if i get a if i own a fast food
chain i want to call it asperger's
[Laughter]
yeah the buns could have two little like
mounds on top
oh they actually look like ass how about
that so autistic
welcome
all right it's easier to hold it might
fall apart though all right what is this
what game are we playing
capture the thing oh we're capturing it
with this capture it's a small
get this man his water
stronghold
my face exploded all right let's um
let's let's get this done they're coming
at a get this i'm trying to get three
kills already aimbot jacob
well he has a sniper rifle he's actually
picking up power weapons which to be
fair is something i'm not doing yet
it's
[Music]
that's adorable i want that uh we should
group up i'm with you alana i'm on
oh yeah what the [ __ ] guys what happened
i'm capturing alpha okay
underneath
oh they're behind us yeah jacob's beta
how do you know how
in my opinion a really a beta move is
like people who care when you make fun
of them jacob
jacob he don't care
i am a
punching bag someone calls you a baiter
and you don't have any reaction to it
that's alpha
mm-hmm but if you get called the beta
and you're upset about it you're a
[ __ ] data mate you might if you're
i'm good i'm getting it i'm getting it i
killed a blue kitty b there's two of b
i'm all seen
you're the only woman on the team yeah
but i was fine that you don't go into
these things alone right
it is great it feels wonderful i'm a big
fan oh i'm getting destroyed by these
lots
are you pushing c right now yeah oh yeah
uh i'm underneath see i'll go for it i
am going to wait for you to arrive
there's too many of this too many of
them up there there's too many of them
[ __ ] hell these lot are sticking
together that's what nice one they're
dead
but if you look at their kills they've
only got two four and two yeah but it's
an objective based game that does not
require you right underneath us let's
join up with lawrence yeah
jacob knows what that
is it's mars guo he was my main in star
wars episode one racer sniper's up
okay oh i'm almost uh i've almost played
through galactic battlegrounds that's
the
oh wow how is that
it is literally age of empires too it
just has star wars things on it so i
mean it's good oh i played a bit of that
star wars
wow oh there might i dropped a shotty
and a sniper on my core
stronghold alpha lost
that's fine we're gonna wait the guy
just ran past it luckily open up there's
another one he might see
i'm coming rahul
jesus
damn
uh i'll head towards you
shields up charlie uniform november
tango
this guy went down the dang hole
we're holding right behind you you got
the sniper
yeah nice i think they do have a did
they not
oh
i keep forgetting about all the
equipment that i haven't yeah i'm i'm
not taking advantage of the haloiness of
the video game really at all at this
point okay we got beeble we lost we need
to get one
oh you gotta oh nice nice i need to get
a point back and he killed me oh
okay when i respawn i'll try and group
back up uh and then i'll yeah i'll move
over to where you go yeah we need to get
two points to get scoring
again stronghold bravo okay yeah oh yeah
you're right um yeah what do we want to
push b or a let's go b let's go b yeah
hey they're right there oh no okay yeah
but rahul this isn't about killing it's
about capping oh
there's a lot of grenades yeah
but they would have shot us because they
were [ __ ] behind us
[Laughter]
oh wait the overshield's up we do need
to get seats
i'm at sea or i'm almost at sea
i got my overshield oh my god how did
that even happen
yeah it wasn't like me in the [ __ ]
mouth
yeah
while i was capping and not killing
yeah
stink hole was taken i guess it was oh
no
[ __ ] hell guys threw a grenade and it
bonked off the back of rubble's head and
blew me up for a whole um
but i don't know okay
got it okay we gotta get one other point
b lawrence do you want to push the b
yeah yeah b's the closest one to us
texas
okay
c is close up for me right now but guys
it's really weak nice let's get b
i'm just kind of killing everyone yeah
i'm seeing that you're killing not
capping okay we gotta keep them off of a
now because they're gonna try and take a
three
oh alana you [ __ ] idiot i deserve
that kill and i [ __ ] it up underneath
boom
one of them's going underneath to get to
a
oh my shit's out of ammo
nice nice all right pushing it pushing
pushing there's one guy there the
shields are down but they're coming back
he's leaving i think yeah
okay
just one guy so let's stay together got
him yeah he's got another heads up if
you're going to b he's got an overshield
he's heading towards c now i'm going for
c
enemy
you want to grab b while you're over
there
i'm going to i'll grab you
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh i don't like being out in the open
like this
where are we going jacob c
yeah well we got two points let's just
kill people
oh because we have two points and now we
can start scoring
oh
let's get back
[Music]
oh he's on b his overshield's gone but
he's on b okay i'm going around a b
damn it heads up if you're alone no i
keep i keep dramatically overestimating
how high i can jump
oh yeah
nice good team shooting
okay
trying to cap c triple cap coming triple
k's are going towards a problem
[Applause]
game
that was a spicy one yeah that was going
back and forth
now we're playing halo that was fun
that was really fun